hello everyone and welcome to tonight's
episode of beginner breakdown thank you
for joining me my name is alex mullering
and i'm going to be talking you through
our adventure tonight
and i have a fun one planned for you
this evening we're going to be talking
about combinations so
uh combinations are when you use
different tactics strategies and ideas
and put them together uh and so last
week i looked at a lot of
uh different games and different ideas
and that was i think cool but this one
my plan is we're gonna work through a
whole bunch of different tactics and all
put it together to work on one final
game
so uh let's start at the very beginning
now this is a super super basic uh
idea that you see before you right here
many of you are gonna be familiar with
it it's called a back rank um
and the idea is simple right when we
have a king
who is
stuck behind their pawns on this last
rank when we're looking at the board
right we have the ranks which are these
horizontal
uh lines and the files which are the
vertical ones
and so when a king is on this last rank
here whether it's the first or the
eighth
and stuck behind usually they're pawns
but it could be something else
and we have an ability to attack
everything in this row
that's going to be a back rank so in
this position white to move
rook to e8 is going to be checkmate
because we have hit the king
where it hurts there's no escape square
and the king's own pawns are blocking
freedom
so again super super basic but we're
going to build up and we're going to see
how if we can start putting these really
basic elementary ideas together it's
going to get a little more complicated
all right so here's our next example
it's white to move
anybody in the audience or the chats
have any suggestions for how to proceed
again not super complicated but you
gotta start somewhere
queen takes e8
okay
and then rook takes
yeah this is important because if we
take with the queen first
then after rook takes rook takes the
king still has an escape now
we have a rook so we're still fine um
but if you take with the rook first
rook has to take because the queen is
cutting off the escape
and when the queen takes it's the same
idea right the king is back ranked
because all of these squares are cut off
and the queen
is cutting off this final escape square
as well whereas the rook wouldn't have
done that
so okay so now we put a little bit more
together right we can see that we can
look at a few different pieces attacking
the same square
and the same back rank pattern is
available even though right the king
isn't completely covered because we can
use the queen to cover it back
all right let's move to the next one a
little more complicated but still
shouldn't be too too hard
black to move
how should we proceed from here
okay rook b1
and the problem for white here
is again this in a regular game i mean
rook b1 looks like a normal move
but white might not even realize what a
big problem it is right because it looks
like the king has plenty of space
but if we really get down to it
the king's in a lot of trouble this
knight is cutting off this key square
the bishop is cutting off this key
square
the pawn's on the way and the rook is
hitting the rest so you have to block
only one move to do so
and checkmate
so again not too simple but we got to
start out uh really solid we're kind of
building up a tower we got to start from
the bottom
okay so we have the back rank pretty
well recognized the king is cut off from
moving up whether by their own pieces or
ours and we have one piece that hits in
a straight horizontal line that's going
to come in and take out the king
okay here's the next piece we got to put
it discovered check
so a discovery just in general
is anytime you move a piece and the
piece behind it uh is released doing an
attack so in this case again shouldn't
be too hard can anybody find our
discovered check here
yeah
again don't worry we'll get a little
more advanced here but the idea with 95
is
we get to attack the queen
and the king so they have to deal with
the threat on the king uh the rook
attacking this is the discovery but the
fact that it's a check makes it even
worse
because you either are just going to
lose the queen
or um
it's it better would be to do this and
then at least you get a knight for it
but still
white with a rook is going to be more
than adequate to finish off this game
so again the main idea of discovery is
removing this piece of the piece behind
it can attack
let's move to this next example
a little more complicated a lot of
pieces on the board a lot more options
so let's take a minute
and again if you have a suggestion
either in the chat or here in our live
audience feel free to
to shout it out but take some time and
calculate this position see what the
best way to continue for white is
anyone have any suggestions how should
we play
okay knight c6 uh the idea right we are
uh calling check with the rook and
actually in this case also with the
knight
all right um in this position i have two
options
let's say
let's just say i go to f7
okay and i'll take back with the rook
and now what
uh bishop c4 okay
uh looks like i
well i could push this pawn yeah let's
do that
and i think we've gotten into a little
bit of trouble right we started out
strong and we did win a queen but in
this position it looks like uh there was
some kind of trade here where we gave up
our queen
so if we actually count the pieces in
this variation
uh it's kind of weird i think black's
actually winning by very slightly right
we both have two rooks we both have two
bishops
uh we both have a knight and black just
has these extra two pawns
so
uh
believe it or not black's actually
surviving in this variation so let's try
something else
how can we maximize the power of our
discovery the queen is nice but
amazingly it's not quite enough
okay so this makes sense again we're
doing a double check so same thing as
last time uh this time we're going to g6
and there's a subtle difference on this
square that wasn't present in the last
one and uh
anybody help me identify what's
different about putting the knight here
then on c6
yeah so the knight on c6 actually gives
black an escape
over here
the bishop and the rook are coming
together so there's only one move uh
anytime there's a double check you have
to move the king
because obviously right if if i take the
knight the rook still takes me and if
something let's say this pawn is here it
can't take our rook because again the
knight's attacking so a double check is
a really powerful tool in our arsenal so
because that king has to move and
there's only one square can go king f7
and from here how should we continue
yeah
that actually not just winning the rook
but winning the game
cutting off every square um and this is
checkmate
let's go to our third example here
a little bit harder
a lot's going on in this position so
take your time again and see if you can
find the best idea for white
uh in this position
so
okay
knight g5 uh
i will
bring the king back to h8
knight f7
yeah so this is a queen sacrifice um and
there's no other way to make progress in
this position amazingly
yeah and again we can't take this piece
as much as we'd like to because it's a
double check right the bishop is the one
also
involved we only have one move here
right the pawn and the bishop are
cutting off everything else
and now knight f7
forking the king and queen and more
importantly winning the game
so we now have two
uh tools here two tactical ideas in our
arsenal we have the back rank
we have the discovered check
we're gonna add a third one in here this
one's gonna again we're gonna keep
slowly ramping up the difficulty
but we're gonna start easy
then uh familiar with this position
yeah i'm seeing some nods uh from the
audience obviously the move here is rook
to d8 does anyone know what this is
called
this uh mating pattern
sorry
uh cornermate i think is something
slightly different
this is actually called the opera mate
and it's named after the really famous
game with paul morphy the morphe opera
house which we may look at another day
but we'll actually see that example uh
coming up here but the idea
is the bish sorry the rook and the
bishop work together to cut off
basically every square the king can go
usually there's one left so something
else has to cover that either their own
piece or one of ours
but this is another really powerful tool
that we're going to add in with our back
rank
and our discover check okay
black to move in this position
and see if we can find
a winning idea
all right hey it's faye in the chat has
a interesting idea uh anyone in the
audience want to take a shot
yeah you can see oh you can see the chat
well uh yeah queen d1 so great job
and again uh it's kind of a bold move
sacking a queen but when we can
calculate it out it looks fine and the
idea is our rook
and our bishop are already in this
beautiful spot
so we can give up the queen
because we have our opera
and it's again similar to a back rank
except we're defending the rook instead
of it just being farther away and so
we're cutting off all these squares
king can't escape
so really nice find
how about this position black to move
any ideas here
for our hero black
h4
uh queen h4 okay
uh g6 or sorry g3
it's a block
yeah so this one is an interesting idea
there's actually a different pattern
that this is based around um probably a
better move is actually to move away
because if g6 we can get this nice fork
but even
stronger is what you said yeah queen f1
and again very similar to our last
position
where we put the queen here uh forcing
like the king to be totally stuck and we
get our opera
the same thing here
the king has nowhere to go
in this case the king is the one who
takes and now how do we finish it
bishop d3 and again you can't take our
piece because it's a discovered check
so that's how that piece is coming into
play uh we have one option king 2
e1 and hopefully yeah rook 2.
f
1 finishing the game here
all right let's look at our next one and
this one is actually from
the
opera house game right the famous game
with paul morphy in the 1800s so you may
have seen this position before
but it's still really really valuable
okay queen b8 knight takes
exactly and this is actually getting
into an idea that we're going to talk
about uh very briefly but this is a new
tactic
called deflection
uh we're making this knight move away
and the knight is actually doing a
really pivotal job of keeping our rook
from this square
but because it has to move right there
there's no other options we get our
beautiful opera mate
and our last example here
and hopefully you're starting to sense
the pattern
but the point isn't too tricky but it's
to use these tools that we can build a
pattern and put them all together to
actually play a strong game
so how should whites continue here
okay queen d8 only option is i'm going
to take it
yeah bishop a5 and we're setting up the
rook and bishop
and there's no tricky ideas i can't take
the bishop i can't block it because it's
again double check this really really
critical idea
so in this position the king has to move
and wherever you move it doesn't make a
difference
the work is coming to d8
okay so we now have three tools in our
toolkit we have the back rank discover
check and also sort of double check
and this opera made
we're gonna add i believe two more sort
of three more um but
two more main ideas and this one is the
one we were just talking about a moment
ago this is deflection
and we're going to talk about this and
then another concept called undermining
does anybody in the audience know uh
what deflection or undermining are
i sort of explained deflection but
yeah we're making a piece uh that is
doing some kind of critically important
job of defending uh we're forcing it
away so in this position it's white to
move
and uh
we're going to deflect an important
piece away from its job
anyone have a suggestion for how we can
get an advantage here
right to move
yeah
bishop h7 and the king should take but
no matter what it does it's been removed
from defending this rook
so we're gonna be ahead right we have a
rook for a bishop and a pawn now
um and the difference between deflection
and undermining we'll talk about when we
get to that section but
they're doing a very similar thing we're
making a piece move somewhere it
doesn't want to be because it's doing
some important job
all right this position uh white to move
and play the winning idea
we have an extra pawn we would love for
it to become a queen it is desperately
trying but
if black is able to stop it it's going
to be a draw so what can we do
uh rook a3 check okay uh king probably
b4
yeah and now we can move to defend the
pawn um but then probably the king can
just
well no king can't go there but
maybe something like
this
and the king's going to come after the
pawn or the rook and
it's going to be hard to continue here
someone in the chat actually found this
one
and the idea is really critical rook g5
we're sacrificing the rook but we're
actually creating this pin
so the the rook is now tied down and
can't move off this rank
and so after they take
we get our queen and
coincidentally enough we actually also
get the rook so we don't have to do the
hard work of a queen of king versus a
queen a king in rock
um so again really important idea the
rook is doing a super important job of
stopping this pawn from promoting
and we completely nullify that through
in this case another tactica pin so
again hey it's fife well done on that
one
all right
deflection number three
how should we
proceed from here white to move
okay rook to f8
uh kind of an opera pattern right our
queen and rook instead of the bishop and
rook uh no other option so queen has to
take
yeah
we have our rook and queen doing a lot
of work putting pressure on uh the king
here
but we can't do it because our queen's
keeping us occupied
so we deflected away we force the queen
to move obviously king can't take
and after the queen moves it's no longer
defending our critical square and we get
checkmate so again deflection is a super
super important tool and it's not always
easy to see but
hopefully we can build some of that
pattern recognition
okay another kind of complicated one
but we have
white to move here
okay we have someone in the chat
uh stung i believe
queen takes g7
is our
suggestion okay i believe
uh we could follow that with knight
takes
and what's your follow-up
yeah the knight is defending the square
so unfortunately
there's not going to be enough
now i'll tell you what we would love to
do is we would love to have this kind of
smothered idea right where the king is
fully trapped because of our rook
but um unfortunately this doesn't work
queen is covering
so how can we make any progress on this
position
h4
yeah really beautiful queen
h4 i'm once again sacrificing the queen
um
but in this case
we are removing the guard so probably
the best move in this case is actually
going to be like f6
and then we can just take the queen
now if you wanted to play a knight takes
queen
which looks fine it actually doesn't
work because they're just going to get
ours as well and it's going to be a big
trade
so we have to yeah we have to play here
give up our queen
and they either lose the game
or they lose their queen
so that's deflection again we're forcing
a piece away from this key square it's
defending
undermining is a very similar idea but
the difference is
we're actually going to
take the piece instead of forcing it
away
so
in this position it's uh right to move
how can we gain an advantage here
so again very similar to deflection but
we're actually going to remove the piece
instead of pulling it away
yeah queen h5 uh and the knight is doing
this really important job defending the
bishop so after takes
pawn takes
now what
okay rook g7 kh8
g6
so rook g6 looks really good i think
there's a bit of a problem with uh
well i guess e5 i can still just uh take
the queen
and rook g5 is actually probably going
to be even a little worse because of the
same reason
uh i would probably just play
rook d7 here
and i'm gonna win the queen
i don't think there's a way to force a
checkmate in that position but here it's
gonna be good enough when we have two
bishops
uh in addition to our rooks
yeah after
rook g6 yeah i think
it's probably gonna be the same but i
guess the difference is now
they're gonna get this piece
so it's we're still better but um
i would probably go to d7
uh yeah liberated toast you got the
right idea
all right
undermining example two
wait to move what should we do here
okay
yeah
rookie again we're looking at what is
the most important square here our queen
and our united are attacking
but it's defended so let's remove the
defender
probably
like obviously if you take the rook with
either piece
it is checkmate
so probably the best you can do is check
and then
i don't know maybe
g6
but even this i don't think is going to
ultimately work we can play something
like this and
we're going to win at least the rook
if not more
so yeah the idea is we're really
critically removing this uh defender of
our pawn
all right
next one and then uh we have two more
examples here of undermining and then
we're gonna start to see how this is
coming together
so again black to move in this position
we need to find a way to break through
rook f2 okay uh i will take back with
the rook
yep
uh removing the defender here the pawn
was our critical defender uh king back
to f1
and
yeah
beautiful checkmate finishing it off um
and it's not gonna change if you like go
back this is now just
checkmate
um
so yeah it's part of
this undermining and deflection business
is we have to understand what are the
really critical points that if we could
remove one piece
man this was this is the piece to do
uh
[Music]
uh what happens if you take with
what do you mean
oh yeah well the difference here is
it's not check so uh we're we're giving
them the option to what should white do
here
uh well if they take it back it's gonna
be exactly the same right
uh or no i'm sorry the knight's
defending this pawn
oh yeah you're right sorry bishop queen
and this is going to be exactly the same
but there is a critical difference they
can't take with the rook but they have a
better move
yeah
yeah since it's not check uh our queen
is hanging so we have to be a little
careful there but yes yeah
all right last example of undermining
here
white to move
yeah hey it's fifi got it again um our
key square in this position
is here on f7 right we have our rooks
beautifully lined up ready to invade
problem is the knight is defending so
what do we do we remove it queen takes
f6
and now if you take back
rook takes
check
and
mate because the knight is guarding here
on g6
uh and if you don't take
i'm not really sure what you do
i don't think it really matters
um
yeah
because the problem is uh one you've
lost a piece at worst but i mean even
worse i'm just gonna sack here and now
my queen and like this is over
um
you can try something like this and then
it's checkmate here or if you take
you can't even take its pins so yeah
that's rough
um okay so now
uh right tactics is fun puzzles are fun
but i want to put this all together
so we're going to look now at some
combinations
where we're using some of these things
together
our tools on our repertoire are back
ranks discovered checks and double
checks uh the opera mate deflection and
undermining so let's start piecing this
together uh and i have a few examples
where we're gonna do that and then we're
gonna look at a game together that
really puts all of this together
beautifully
so
again uh this one a little simpler but
we're gonna remove the guard
uh what can we do in this position as
white to get an advantage
uh yeah and you kind of have two options
here um
queen takes queen is the best one
because now you just can't take it back
right because if you take it back we
have this back rank so uh we did a
deflection here right we took the queen
and under my or sorry we didn't
undermine the queen we deflected uh the
rook so you probably just have to do
something else i don't know
um you can also play rook e8 here and
it's going to do a similar thing but the
difference is they got a rook then i
don't like giving away things so i would
rather have a rook and a queen um
yeah liberty toaster uh i'll quickly go
back for you but the idea of the opera
mate
is uh it's based on morphe's famous
opera game and it's this pattern where
the bishop and the rook are kind of
working together to cover all of these
squares
so this is the opera mate pattern
all right so back to where we were so we
removed the guard
uh queen d7
yeah i mean this looks good we're
threatening
uh checkmate right um
i wonder
like i mean this is well you i think you
give the opportunity just to play h6
right and lessen the tension um and like
we can still trade but now i don't think
we're getting anything out of it
um so yeah definitely best move is uh
take the queen and second best is to uh
force the rook away but either case
we're making this piece
uh it's
it's doing too much it's overworked yeah
all right black to move
how can we
gain an advantage in this position
so it may be a little more complicated
so take some time if you need to
uh queen takes b4
yeah someone was saying something about
g5
but i don't really know what that's
about but yeah queen takes b4 um
and the idea is knight takes and then
what
yep and uh king h2
yep trick question
so it's uh it's a back rank setup still
because even though it looks like the
king has an escape our bishop is
covering the exit um and this one is
actually kind of cool because it looks
like like white's probably not expecting
this at all because one it's a queen
sack
one two they have the back rank pushed
so they think they might be okay
um and they have two pieces covering
this square but we can deal with both of
them in one move it's really just brutal
um so probably best move is going to be
something like here but
there's nothing you can do to stop it at
best we've won a piece
sorry at worst
so yeah again really really good find
next position here
we'll get to that uh hey it's fifa yeah
it's nice to spot these in game uh we'll
talk about that uh once we finish these
next two
so light to move
uh i believe i don't remember what game
this was from but i believe uh the move
just played was bishop to f5 attacking
the queen
yeah queen takes bishop kind of simple
idea here right we've uh seen this
before and the queen now deflected it's
tied down
defending the crucial background square
and the queen
and so yeah this is just very
unfortunate uh white has just won a
piece
and finally here
white's a move
this is a harder one there's a lot going
on but
yeah you and uh stung in the chat both
got at the same time queen to g4 really
really brilliant move
uh obviously we're threatening checkmate
on g7
um
but there's a few problems right our
rook is hanging and our queen is hanging
but you can't take either now certainly
you can't take the rook because it's
checkmate
but you also can't take the queen
because it's checkmate
um
and unfortunately you have to stop
your you have to save your king
so actually black's queen is the one
that's hanging in this position
remarkably despite all of the positions
here
so probably something like uh g6 and we
can take the queen
and uh i don't you can't even take the
rook because now we're still threatening
this back rank
so really really brutal um but yeah
great find queen to g4
and uh yeah to the point of
tactics and seeing them in games is i
have this thought kind of this love-hate
relationship with tactics where i think
it's so good to practice them and then
i'm like yeah but i know that this is
the critical position so i know when i'm
looking through tactics or doing puzzles
that i can stop spending my time here
because there's something here oh my
goodness
hello msn outlook we are not sponsored
um
so
uh yeah because i know there's something
to look for here and it's hard to do
that in the games but the point i think
of these tactics is to build that
pattern recognition into your head so
you've seen it before right we've all
seen a back rank
um and so having that in our minds we're
able to spot positions in games where
maybe that will be a relevant feature
and that's just one less calculation we
have to do because we can see that
pattern and then build from it
so all of that said we're going to move
into a really really cool game that
features all of these points so let's
keep them in our mind we have back ranks
discover checks and double checks uh we
have this opera mate pattern and then we
have deflection undermining where we're
either drawing a piece away or removing
it entirely by taking it um
and putting all of that together we're
going to start to
be able to see how a grand master might
play
so this is a super cool game it's i was
played in ukraine in 1931 and there's a
series of chess games called the
immortal games uh this is one of them
this is called the ukrainian immortal
and it was between uh fm korchbar and uh
adam polyak so again this was an old
game
but it's got some really really cool
combinations that use a lot of these
ideas so let's see if we can figure it
out as we go
okay so uh
white
plays e4
e5
knight to f3 knight to c6 and bishop to
b5 so we have a roy lopez um anybody in
here play this for white or black
no okay um it's a super popular opening
at all levels of the game so if you
don't play you've probably seen it um
and i mean it just kind of makes sense
white is developing their pieces in a
very principled way right night before
bishop king said before queen side we're
preparing to castle
and we're putting a lot of pressure in
the center um
since it seems like we have a little
less of a familiarity
with this position let's just briefly
talk kind of the point
um
point is again we're threatening e5
i will say it's not a direct threat
and one of i don't know if it's the most
popular
master level yeah a6 okay it is so
a6 and i actually i think this is
actually morphe's move of choice funny
enough in this position
um
but it seems like white can win a pawn
right we're gonna play bishop take c6
pawn takes and it's important to capture
uh with this pawn i mean you can play
this move but uh this move saves us a
turn in development it's going to be
easier to bring this bishop out so
activating that's important
and it looks like white can just went
upon
there's a bit of a problem how could
black you know kind of equalize this
uh sorry which one
yeah queen d4 um probably the best move
you can also play queen to g5 and in
either case uh we're going to be hitting
multiple targets
and so we're going to be winning back at
least the pawn if not more
so
so again
we're not just winning this pawn but it
does put a lot of pressure uh and we're
going to start to maybe work towards
that
so that's something to keep in mind and
in this game instead of a6 uh or like
knight f6 which is the berlin defense
another really popular response nowadays
uh
black in this position played the move
d6
and this is uh called
the steinitz defense or sometimes the
old steinitz defense um
and it's
was played again more frequently uh in
the past it still sees play at all
levels um
but it has a few problems
uh can anybody help me out identify
maybe some opening issues with
this d6 move
yeah it's one right we uh do allow our
white light squared bishop to get in but
at the cost of kind of losing some
versatility with this bishop
a lot of times you would like to play
something like bishop c5 first before
you would do this type of move
so that's one issue uh anybody have any
other
yeah we got a liberty toaster the knight
is now pinned
absolutely pinned to the king
so now
we have alleviated some of the tension
with our pawn but maybe this knight is
gonna be a little more problematic and
actually because of this it actually
allows white to play
really
really quickly
with the move d4
right and we're threatening now there is
a serious threat on e5
because we can capture eventually with
our knight against this pinned piece and
maybe cause some problems
we're also making a big threat of just
playing d5
and
you know black can maybe
have some counter play with again a6 if
that happens but it's going to be
uncomfortable
white's definitely going to enjoy these
pawns
uh advanced
so
because of that black really is forced
into one of two options here
in this position you're either going to
break the pin
or you're going to take the pawn
and i in the game we have bishop to d7
taking the pawn is doable um to me it
looks maybe a little
drawish right the knight's going to come
in and then the bishop's going to come
and it's going to be kind of the same
but instead yeah we have bishop to d7
and now just some kind of really it
moves it just makes sense continue from
here white plays knight to c3 and knight
to f6 so we're developing our pieces uh
castle
and then we have a big exchange knight
takes d4
bishop takes
queen takes knight takes pawn takes
queen tanks
so huge exchange there um and in the end
i would say white comes out a little bit
better
um
just because we have a little more
center control and our pieces are easier
to develop right this d6 pawn is still
interfering with the bishop
versus our bishop really has a lot of
versatility a lot of options all of
these squares look great uh plus we are
already castled so that's one less
developing style move uh needed from
white
but it's obviously not like white's not
winning here it's just a slight
advantage
uh bishop e7 you know developing the
last piece
rook to d1
and black castles
and in this position
uh white plays a really really strong
move
so i don't have a suggestion for what
white should do to continue it's the
best move in this position
i've seen a few suggestions in the chat
f4 and e5 have both been suggested any
other suggestions here
well let's take a look at those um f4 i
do like um
some of the point is maybe you're
preparing to play e5 and you're
supporting it with this pawn
i think
uh e5 is a little better
one because we don't need f4 yeah like
myc613 like you said um e5 can't be
taken
we have the queen and rook together
and it's forming a pin right should they
take which would be a blunder queen
takes knight takes rook takes we traded
queens but we want a knight
so e5 can't be taken which means we
don't really need f4 to support it uh
the other thing with f4 is maybe one day
we want this bishop on g5 or f4 itself
so
uh we don't want to necessarily lock in
our
bishop a little more than necessary so
f4 not a bad move but e5 really strong
here
uh so in the game this is actually now
an important question so how should
black continue since taking the pawn
just doesn't work
what would you do if you were in black's
position here
okay liberated toaster would resign well
this is not you know
white whites maybe has an advantage but
we gotta we gotta play these things out
let's not resign so early
uh we gotta move the knight yeah we
don't want to lose this piece but where
do we put it
e8 has been suggested
probably
i mean i guess you could play knight to
h5 but i don't really want to put mine
on the edge of the board uh g4
seems like an option
yeah stung suggesting knight g4 so
what do you think is better between e8
and g4 because those really look like
our only two
viable
anyone have a preference
or if you have another suggestion
okay
how come
because
yeah this is definitely going to get us
cramped um blacks wants these rooks
connected and
you know obviously the knight wants to
be more active
unfortunately there is a problem with
the knight on g4 as uh
hey it's fifi as pointed out
um
someone also suggesting queen to g4
uh but then yeah you just lose the
knight that doesn't work
because uh the rook is defending
so yeah knight to g4 the problem is the
knight can get kicked around so
something like f3
and now if well now that knight's really
stuck you have
you can either go back to h6 where i
will happily take you
and just destroy this castle
which will be fun to attack later
or you can take this pawn and how should
i continue here
yep
and again we're relying on the same pin
so
uh we're either going to trade queens or
not but white gets the knight either way
so
so yeah moving to g4 looks good but it
does have some problems so knight e8 was
played in the game for that reason
um okay
white plays bishop to f4 so wanting to
support
this advance and again still we're
capitalizing on the fact that this pawn
is pinned
so it can't ever take so whenever you
have a pinned piece you want to add more
pressure
a5 played in the game
which looks a little odd but there is a
point to it
and the next two moves were rook to d3
and rook to a6
so we have two rook lifts
um
one of them is significantly better than
the other one though
uh i think the point of this move right
a5 to open up the rook is we're adding a
defender to d6 um and maybe recognizing
that it's going to get a little
clustered here on the back rank because
of the knight
but
because this pawn is on d6 the rook
scope is pretty limited
we don't have the option to come over
and be aggressive on the king side like
we would like to
versus if we look at white's rook this
is a really great rook lift because now
we have the option to go to any of these
squares and just really mess with the
king
and this is going to be a very powerful
attacking idea for
uh white
so uh continuing from here so we just
have the rook lifts rook to e1
queen comes to f5
and this is maybe a bit of a mistake
because it allows white to take some
initiative here so
what should white play in this position
what might you play if you were white
all right thanks for stopping in hey
it's
fifi uh yeah mic 613
suggesting knight d5
uh this is just a great move right we're
centralizing our piece and we're making
a huge threat uh the problem with queen
f5 is it's kind of just allowing this
we're threatening to take the bishop
which is not defended um
and then fork the king and the queen
so this leaves uh black in a tough spot
bishop to d8
me
maybe not forced i guess you could maybe
play here but then just g6 and it goes
back and
so it's
kind of forced um
maybe you could play like queen back to
e6 and defend but then there's risks of
discoveries right
um
so bishop back to d8 and now we can see
there's a big positional problem right
black's pieces just aren't doing
anything and white's pieces are really
beautifully placed in the center
but now our question is how do we take
advantage
of this as white
so in this position um i'll show you the
next move we have pawn takes pawn which
normally uh you know i i think it's fair
because right the pins not there anymore
so there's not really a point to holding
on to this tension and it's actually
important that we do this because white
wants to not really mess with this this
isn't what's important
but we want to open up the queen
because now our queen and our lifted
rook can start to make some really
significant threats
knight takes pawn
probably with the idea that one we want
to get our piece more active and if we
take with the pawn then our rook is
stuck again so knight takes makes sense
to me
and then we have i believe
rook to g3
and yet like i said with this pawn out
of the way now we have a
checkmate threat
so
let's put ourselves in the shoes of the
black player again
what would you do in this position how
do we
not get checkmated
how do we continue this game what's the
best idea
uh bishop f6 with a definite question
mark from uh
abravanel 777 yeah problem here
is there's too much attacking right this
pawn is pinned
so it's not actually a defender so if we
can just take this piece
and if you take with the queen
then
you just lost your queen
so bishop f6
not quite it
f6
suggested i believe this is what was
played in the game
um let me ask what if um what was the
other move yeah what if g6 is played
right
uh now one more spot root what
uh or knight of six you mean yeah yeah
knight f6 yeah now this is a little
tough um
well let's see what if bishop takes
how do you continue from here
yeah i think the problem is the reason
we could get away with it when the
bishop was here is because we'd already
lost that piece
uh
now there are enough defenders of this
square
that we can't just abuse it
unfortunately but yeah a few people in
the chat have found yeah bishop h6
really really strong
because there's not really any good way
for black to handle this we're
threatening the rook we're threatening
checkmate
the rook can't move because then we we
can still i'm sorry then we still have
checkmate
um so if something like f6 now then we
can just take it
and maybe play something like rook f3
and uh this looks really really rough
so
g6 doesn't work so in the game f6 is the
move that was played
and now with a similar idea white plays
bishop to h6 uh
exploiting the pinned pawn and now
hoping to you know take with the rook
and we already saw if g6 is played this
is going to transpose to what we just
saw
we will just take the rook
and play here
and this is really unfortunate because
you know we have three pieces attacking
there's two pieces defending and one of
them's about to move
so for that reason in the game uh black
played rook to f7
uh knight e8 suggested what's the
problem with knight e8
how should white continue here
oh before f6
well i think in this position um
we'll start with this one i think the
problem here
i i wonder if we can just take this
right i think we can do our deflection
and after rook takes
uh rook or maybe even bishop takes here
no you have to do rook because there's a
background thread against us
this is going to be interesting i'm not
sure
i'm not confident but
i know there is a problem with it um
before f6 uh
knight back to e8
here is what you're saying
um
well here we just take it because we're
threatening checkmate if you take back
so this one would be a deflection
um okay but let's get back to our game
so work f7
and this is where all of it comes
together uh i'm going to show you this
move because i would never find it um
really incredible move from white here
knight to b4
just fully sacrificing the night but the
point is
um we're looking at all these tactics
together and we're gonna do some
deflection we're gonna do some
undermining we're gonna threaten some
back ranks so here's our back rank
threat
a lot is happening
so after pawn takes knight does anyone
see
how white can continue uh to get an
advantage
queen takes knight beautiful absolutely
beautiful
and now
there's really nothing if you take with
the rook or the pawn the result is the
same
check
check
really really unfortunate
or black there uh and all that comes
from this deflection right and this uh
background threat
so okay so that you can't take uh with
the rook or the pawn
so what if something like bishop e7 is
played
well we can just take it
again same thing
if you take
uh the queen it's going to be the same
as we just saw if you take the rook
um
probably
probably just here
maybe not
yeah quindy a first
king comes out here then we take here
and now
yeah
so
queen these queen takes d6 really
beautiful idea so in the game it was
played was queen to d7 and another just
kind of shocking move
queen to d5 playing off the same idea
we've pinned the rook
uh and the queen cannot leave right it's
tied to this square
so we are kind of threatening to deflect
the queen
okay so if the say right if the queen
takes it's kind of the same story
um if king h8 is played
what should we do here
queen takes queen uh rope takes
back rank
brutal uh so in the game because of all
that you can't take
you can't play the king to h8 so king to
f8 was played and how did white finish
this game
just with style
any suggestions here
rook
d6 i think that was oh right now
oh you were looking at um
if rook sorry
here and then if rook d6 is that what
you're saying
then we just take here
because the rook is pinned
so queen d5 uh king f8 the idea here i
think somebody said it
rook to rook takes g7
uh
and the problem is we're gonna discover
this uh check
in the game we had queen takes d5 but if
rook takes
then we just take the queen and the rook
is pinned
and if uh rook to d6 right this was kind
of the question his rook takes f7
checkmate
so in the game queen to d5 and our last
variation
how do you get checkmate from here
wait to win i think in three or four
uh rook h7
i don't think works
because of uh here
so there's a more better move than rook
uh takes h7 yeah rook g8
because we need to keep the king tied
here
after rook g8 now your idea does work
and we have our beautiful opera
conclusion
so
really beautiful game and hopefully you
were able to follow some of those ideas
a little better because we were able to
put together it our back rank theme our
discover checks double checks this opera
mate and our deflection undermining and
it's not always easy obviously some of
these moves are just incredible knight
to b4 is a brilliancy
but um being able to see these ideas
hopefully can help you recognize in your
own game some of these patterns
um so again thank you for joining
everybody it's been awesome teaching
with you
and i hope to see you again next time